Your Majesty your royal highness
mr. president excellencies ladies and
gentlemen I accept the Nobel Prize for
peace at a moment when 22 million
Negroes of the United States are engaged
in a creative battle to end the long
night of racial injustice I accept this
award on behalf of the civil rights
movement which is moving with
determination and a majestic scorn for
risk and danger and to establish a reign
of freedom and a rule of justice I'm
mindful that only yesterday in
Birmingham Alabama our children crying
out for Brotherhood were answered with
fire hoses snarling dogs and even death
I am mindful that only yesterday in
Philadelphia Mississippi young people
seeking to secure the right to vote were
brutalized and murdered I'm mindful that
debilitating and grinding poverty
afflicts my people and chains them to
the lowest rung of the economic ladder
therefore I must ask why this prize is
awarded to a movement which is
beleaguered and committed to unrelenting
struggle into a movement which has not
yet won the very peace and Brotherhood
which is the essence of the Nobel Prize
after contemplation I conclude that this
award which I receive on behalf of that
movement is a profound recognition that
non-violence is the answer to the
crucial political and moral questions of
our time the need for man to overcome
oppression and violence without
resorting to violence and oppression
civilization and violence are
antithetical concepts Negroes of the
United States following the people of
India have demonstrated that
non-violence is not sterile passivity
but a powerful moral force which makes
for social transformation sooner or
later all the peoples of the world will
have to discover a way to live together
in peace and thereby transform this
pending cosmic elegy into a creative
psalm of brotherhood if this is to be
achieved
man must evolve for all human conflict a
method which rejects revenge aggression
and retaliation the foundation of such a
method is love the torturous road which
has led from Montgomery at Montgomery
Alabama
Oslo bears witness to this truth this is
a road over which millions of Negroes
are traveling to find a new sense of
dignity this same road has opened for
all Americans a new era of progress and
hope it has led to a new civil rights
bill and it will I am convinced be widen
and lengthen into a superhighway of
Justice as Negro and white man in
increasing numbers create alliances to
overcome their common problems I accept
this award today with an abiding faith
in America and an adult audacious faith
in the future of mankind I refuse to
accept despair as a final response to
the ambiguities of history I refuse to
accept the idea that the isness of man's
present nature makes him morally
incapable of reaching up for the eternal
oughtness that forever confronts him I
refuse to accept the idea that man is
mere float 'some and jetsam in the river
of life unable to influence the
unfolding events which surround him I
refuse to accept the view that mankind
is so tragically bound to the starless
midnight of racism and war that the
bright daybreak of peace and brotherhood
can never become a reality I refuse to
accept the cynical notion that nation
after nation must spiral down a
militaristic stairway into the hail of
nuclear annihilation
I believe that on
unarmed truth and unconditional love
will have the final word in reality this
is why right temporarily defeated is
stronger than evil triumphant I believe
that even amid today's mortar bursts and
whining bullets that is still hope for a
brighter tomorrow
I believe that wounded justice lying
prostrate on the blood flowing streets
of our nations can be lifted from this
dust of shame to reign supreme among the
children of men I have the audacity to
believe that people's everywhere can
have three meals a day for their bodies
Education and Culture for their minds
and dignity equality and freedom for
their spirits I believe that what
self-centered men have torn down men of
the Senate can build up I still believe
that one day mankind will bow before the
altars of God and be crowned triumphant
over warden bloodshed and nonviolent
redemptive goodwill proclaimed the rule
of the land and the lion and the lamb
shall lie down together and every man
shall sit under his own vine and fig
tree and none shall be afraid I still
believe that we shall overcome this
faith can give us courage to face the
uncertainties of the future it will give
our tired feet new strength as we
continue our forward stride toward the
city of freedom when our days become
dreary with low hovering clouds and our
nights become darker than a thousand
Midnight's
we will know that we are living in the
creative turmoil of a genuine
civilization struggling to be born today
I come to Oslo as a trusty inspired and
with renewed dedication to humanity I
accept this prize on behalf of all men
who love peace and brotherhood I say I
come as a trustee but in the depths of
my heart I'm aware that this prize is
much more than an honor to me personally
every time I take a flight I'm always
mindful of the many people who make a
successful journey possible the known
polyps and the unknown ground crew you
honor the dedicated pilot of our
struggle who have said at the controls
as a freedom movement soared into orbit
you honor once again chiefly to Lee of
South Africa who struggles with and for
his people a still met with the most
brutal expression of man's inhumanity to
man you honor the ground crew without
whose labored and sacrifice the jet
flights to freedom could never have left
the earth most of these people will
never make the headlines and their names
will never appear in who's who
yet when years have rolled past and when
the blazing light of truth is focused on
this marvelous age in which we live
mammoth men and women will know when
children will be taught that we have a
final land a better people a more noble
civilization
because these humble children of God
were willing to suffer for righteousness
sake
I think Alfred Nobel would know what I
mean when I say I accept this award in
the spirit of a curator of some precious
heirloom which he holds in trust for its
true owners all those to whom truth is
beauty and beauty truth and in whose
eyes a beauty of genuine Brotherhood and
peace is more precious than diamonds or
silver a gold thank you
you